bonjour je me présente je suis le
aurélien de claire je suis atos 4
charognards la patrouille de france 2002
l'objectif de la place de charognards
c'est de devenir leader l'année suivante
l'impression du pilote et elle est très
jeune j'ai grandi à toulon avec avec
aussi la patrouille de france qui
passait régulièrement le 15e notamment
tous ces événements ou
en somme est en moi la graine de
l'aéronautique et je vis actuellement
mon rêve est une passion au quotidien
il ya plein de petites étapes dans une
carrière aéronautique
on passe toutes les qualifications pour
être pilote opérationnel puis sous chef
de patrouille chef de patrouille c'est à
dire pouvoir emmener d'autres avions en
combat et en sur des missions de guerre
par exemple j'ai postulé à la patrouille
de france c'est le costume d'atos 4
pendant un an je passerai au poste de
leader de la patrouille de france 2000
23 qui sera une année un petit peu
particulière aussi avec les 70 ans de la
patrouille de france et à titre
personnel je pense qu'il faut pas avoir
la patrouille de france comme une fin en
soi c'est une étape on est tous issus
d'unités de combat on est tous amenés à
retourner en unités de combat j'ai
évidemment à coeur de pouvoir voler et
dirigé une unité de deux rafale
en renouvelant 30% des pilotes chaque
année et en changeant le poste de chacun
et bien on arrive à créer une
démonstration dans les six mois d'hiver
pour être prêt au rendez vous au mois de
mai et montrer le savoir-faire et
l'excellence de l'armée de l'air dépassé
on a beau être seul dans son à lyon on
est on est vraiment en équipe en vol
pour tous et tous pour un si si je fais
mon ma démonstration seul dans mon avion
seul ce sera pas du tout impressionnant
la même démonstration mais à huit c'est
là que vous appréciez le plus le travail
de la patrouille de france
[Musique]
4101 card
alors en effet
m
j'aurai cette année l'opportunité
d'effectuer la mon premier 14 juillet
tricolore est effectivement une date
très importante comme vous savez il ya
le défilé du 14 juillet la patrouille de
france ouvre le défilé aérien et donc
ouvre aussi le défilé des troupes au sol
le défilé peut paraître simple parce
qu'il est effectivement en ligne droite
c'est un gros travail aussi pour le
leader d'être sur le bon axe avec les
bonnes les bons paramètres et puis il ya
je pense que dans le milieu aéronautique
aucun vol n'est facile d qui a dit que
ça paraît facile c'est qu'il ya quelque
chose qui est sous la cendre dégradation
météo changement d'horaire
gardien qui vient à manquer dans l'avion
parce que pour une raison x ou y les
personnes nées au sol sont sont en
retard les autorités sont en retard par
exemple tous ces petits paramètres vont
faire que ce vol peut devenir difficile
très rapidement on est fier de venir
montrer à la nation et au peuple
français que nous sommes présents que
nous sommes travailleurs c'est
évidemment d'inspirer des jeunes ces
deux inspirés des moins jeunes aussi
continuer à tisser les liens entre nos
armées et la nation